Craig Robertson: What the filing
cabinet did that nothing else
had ever done before is allow
loose paper to stand on its
edge. I think I've caught you up
1890 Thank you, Heather.
Invented 1890. So I'm largely
talking about the early 20th
century for most of this talk.
So what are the advantages of
storing newspaper on its edge?
I'll quickly note two. It's
easier to retrieve a piece of
paper from a filing cabinet on
its edge than from a pile of
papers, right. And it's also
easier to find something
specific. So loose paper can be
grouped together with other
relevant pieces of paper,
regardless of when it was
created. And in fact, it was the
latter that first got me
thinking about filing cabinet
and research for my passport
book. I spent weeks at National
Archives in College Park,
Maryland, looking for references
to passports in thousands of
reels of unindexed microfilm
records of 19th century US
diplomatic correspondence. You
wish you were me. And so one day
though, I arrived at records for
1906. That year is forever
etched in my mind. Because that
year, the State Department
started using a numerical filing
system. And so suddenly, every
diplomatic office had the same
number for passport
correspondence, subdivided by
specific issues and cases and
applications. So rather than
scrolling through formerly bound
pages organized in chronological
order, I could go straight to
where the relevant information
had been gathered in one place.
So subject trumped chronology,
right. And this completely
changed my research and it made
it possible to find documents I
wanted with limited effort.
Okay, I'm just trying to get the
screen going. So my epiphany at
National Archives was one about
classification, but later it
became about storage. When I
discovered that the early 20th
century celebrants of
classification systems that
people who were excited as I was
channeled their excitement into
filing cabinets, right, the key
was the move away from storing
paper, in bound books. So to
hopefully state the obvious, the
filing cabinet stored pieces of
paper, but paper was where
knowledge was recorded, stored
and circulated. So to store
paper was to store information
to make loose paper accessible
was to make information
accessible. Therefore, to use
the filing cabinet was to
interact with information. And
that is why I argue the filing
cabinet is an important object
to study. The filing cabinet
allows us to understand a
fundamental change in the way in
which information was gathered
and stored and reused. A change
that in its staying power
continues to shape interactions
with digital information. So not
only through files on our
computers or tabs on our
browsers. But I would argue with
digital digital assistants like
Siri and Alexa, where women
continue to assist people to
find information. So I
acknowledged the current
contemporary stuff, but this
talk is going to be pretty much
a deep dive into that moment of
emergence. And I do that because
I think it's important to
acknowledge the power relations
that are integral to infinite
information technology is like
the file or the tab. So rather
than an infrastructural tubes
and wires critique, this history
makes information and data
material by showing that the
concepts through which we are
still asked to imagine our
encounters with information and
data files, folders, tabs, etc,
originated in highly gendered
understandings of labor and
information. And so in that
sense, it kind of re-embodies
information by showing that the
properties of the information
technologies associated with
filing are the product of of
historically specific power
dynamics. So therefore, like
again, general point I gave much
earlier for a yes, technologies
have affordances they're
designed to do some things more
easily than others.
In that sense, I examine the
filing cabinet as an object that
is activated in particular ways
it does some things and not
others. And that since I don't
look at the filing cabinet has
been inert or frozen, right, I
think about it as an object and
operation as something that is
activated, right, it's
understood to have emerged as a
solution to a set of problems,
problems about the storage of
paper. However, as a response to
these problems, it generated a
set of processes that affected
thought and action. So
therefore, the other kind of
sort of idea underpinning this
research is the perhaps
hopefully not too radical claim
that storage is not neutral,
right, that storage has a
politics. And of course, this
raises a number of questions,
including, you know, how is
storage constructed as a
problem, what values go into
deciding what to store where to
store how to store? So what were
the problems the filing cabinets
solved, right? Well, as I
suggested, storing loose paper
on its edge allowed it to be
more easily retrieved both the
specific content on a sheet of
paper and also the sheet of
paper itself. So that is the
filing cabinet emerged out of a
rethinking of storage. So in the
1890s, in the office, the
storage of paper becomes a
problem of retrieval. So storage
always involves an awareness of
future use, right. But it does
not always prioritize the moment
in the future when the store
object will be accessed what we
now call retrieval. So as a
practice of piling or
stockpiling, storage,
prioritizes the allocation of
space to store something right
storage takes up space. In
contrast, retrieval is conceived
as a temporal practice, right?
The focus is on a process on
facilitating the act of finding
something retrieval takes up
time. Right. So why then is
storage approached as a problem
of retrieval at the turn of the
20th century? Why that change?
Well, this period, so ideas of
efficiency capture the US
business imagination, as
capitalism takes on its
corporate form, and scale in
this period, saving time emerges
as one of the defining problems
of modern Western society. Now
in the book, this book, this
book, and this book, I offer a
detailed discussion of the
stakes involved in the storage
logic for the filing cabinet. I
focus on three concepts,
verticality, integrity, and
cabinet logic as critical to
understanding its development.
However, all these concepts or
storage logics, logics are
underwritten by a concern to
save time and increase
productivity. So in this talk,
in the spirit of efficiency, I'm
simply going to use efficiency.
To explain why I believe that
the filing cabinet is not a
neutral storage technology,
arguing that efficiency is a
highly gendered discourse,
right? At any period, but
particularly this period. So
efficiency creates the problems
that the filing cabinet solves.
I say problems because the
filing cabinet responds not only
to the problem of timely
retrieval, but also the need for
information in the first place.
So efficiency, productivity
require planning, planning
requires information, it
requires knowing what to produce
and when to produce it.
Therefore, information takes on
a role in business that had
previously not had. And I should
also note, this is the period
when management emerges as a
profession as well. So in the
remainder of this talk, I want
to focus on two ways in which
via efficiency the filing
cabinet shaped a particular kind
of interaction with information.
So first, I'm going to talk
about how the filing cabinet
makes pervasive a concept of
information as a discrete unit
is something that exists in the
world. And then secondly, I'm
going to focus the second part
of the talk will focus on how
the filing cabinet brings to the
foreground a new mode of work
used to handle this information.
Information labor emerges is
something distinct from
knowledge. Okay, so the
emergence of the filing cabinet
provides an important site to
examine a critical moment in the
ascendancy of information is a
defining aspect of contemporary
society right. To have an
information society you need to
have a particular understanding
of information and information
becomes a name for an
instrumental use of knowledge.
Now, as the late Jeffrey Nunberg
showed, the 19th century so
removed from information as an
individual mental process, to be
informed to be educated to a
conception of information that
attaches it to something that
could be possessed and obtained
and received and distributed and
circulated. So information
increasingly becomes thought of
as a discrete unit. Now to be
real clear, I'm not arguing that
the filing cabinet invented this
conception of information. But I
am arguing that it offered a way
to make sense of this change,
right became a way to grasp
information, both physically on
paper and metaphorically. So
this quote up here comes from a
1912 issue of a long lost
magazine called Machinery. And I
like this quote, because it
gives us a sense of this new
conception of information. So
useful information here we can
see was carefully and
systematically collected. And
then it was classified and
digested, digested, not mean,
not being eaten, but put into
digests broken up into pieces
into book that within books,
that is information emerged from
knowledge through an increased
specificity, right and, in
further classification,
objective procedure made
information or allowed people to
argue that this information was
superior, as the quote says, to
individual judgment. So this
process of division took
knowledge and made it accurate
information easily
understandable by anyone. And as
the last sentence is instantly
available, whenever a problem is
presented to management,
efficiency, timeliness. Inside a
filing cabinet, a file drawer
showcases this understanding of
information, in part, because it
used tabbed guide cards and
folders.
With a prop. I have a manila
folder. To make the specificity
to make the specificity and
classification visible. In its
organizational structure, the
file drawer allows information
to be retrieved in its
specificity, a piece of paper,
or a manila folder of loose
papers could be extracted. So
you had all the information on a
particular customer or product
or passport application.
Information was at your
fingertips. And this is the
period when that phrase takes
off. So the idea that info that
you could hold information not
only that you could see it, but
touch it as something discrete,
goes a long way to explaining
how the filing cabinet and
tabbed folder became a
conceptual gateway to understand
modern information. Because of
course, information is something
discrete can be represented in
many different ways within a
statistical table, write the
cells on a table, or in this
period that I'm talking about
the organization of a railway
timetable. But these made the
concept of information harder to
grasp, as I'll continue to pun
on grasped. So as these quotes
appear on the slide suggests
this tactile articulation of
paper and information frequently
appeared in prescriptive
literature. The attraction of
the filing cabinet to the
business information of the
early 20th century was how
quickly it allowed hands to get
at information. It defined
classification, therefore, as a
temporal problem, as much as a
spatial problem, right.
Classification is about
efficiency in this sense.
Filing, we'll get into that
briefly. But q&a? Yes, yes, yes.
lasted for four years, which
comes up a few times. Yeah.
Let's let's have a look.
Basically, as I should say,
every sentence in this talk is
open for q&a. Right? This is a
summary of my book, every source
is open. Yes, but yes, but thank
you for drawing attention to it.
Slide. So ads claimed, a filing
cabinet allowed users to find
papers at a moment's notice, or
almost instantaneously. In the
spirit of the time, these
assertions were quickly
quantified. According to one
very happy customer almost
instantaneously, translated to
20 seconds defined one letter
and 90 seconds to file, file
five folders. That's pretty
fast. And we'll talk about the
hands that are doing that in a
moment. And focusing on
retrieval. a filing cabinet also
challenged ideas of what defined
storage rather than hiding
information in drawers or in
pigeon holes, or lying flat in
piles. This that that former
storage was now understood, did
storage, right? So rather than
that information needed to be
alive needed to be standing at
attention. There is no subtlety
in my archive. Storage was not
dormant or dead when you use a
filing cabinet. In the 1930s,
celebrating the use of a decimal
filing system an advertising
agency president noted quote,
that information does not rot in
our files. It is continuously
shuttling back and forth between
file and everyday business use.
Claiming that quote, within a
few minutes, a clerk could
retrieve sales presentations
from 30 different companies in
30 different fields. He
concluded, thus, our file lives.
Now stepping away from the
specifics of the file drawer, I
want to note that the filing
cabinet and the interior of the
file drawer are examples of a
key technique of efficiency,
what I call granular certainty.
And this is the drive to break
more and more of everyday life.
And its routines into discreet
observable and manageable parts
right granular signifies the
belief that breaking things down
produces a higher degree of
detail or specificity. Certainty
indicates the conviction that
greater specificity will reduce
individual discretion and
increase the likelihood that a
task will be completed
efficiently. Now, obviously,
breaking something down into
small parts allowed it to be
controlled by enabling it to be
more easily apprehended,
understood and connected to
something else. This is the
logic that is central to
Taylorism and the reorganization
of factory labor occurring
according to standardized tasks
occurring at the same time. Now
the analytic value for me of
granular certainty is that it
emphasizes the overlap between
efficiency's embrace of
standardization, and the
particular and a conception of
information as something
discreet. The vertical filing
cabinet and the tabbed manila
folder emerged from this overlap
between efficiency and this new
idea of information. In the file
drawer granular certainty
created a particular cabinet
logic and here we just have an
ad for
150- and 200-division tabbed
folders for alphabetical order
of names so breaking the
alphabet down not into 26
letters, but into 150 or 250
categories. So this cabinet
logic used paper manila folders
tabs to create petitions within
a cabinet drawer to decrease
discretion and increased
certainty. In promotional
literature, this cabinet logic
became, quote, the intellect of
the filing cabinet to help
market the filing cabinet is a
machine. Now, as these quotes
here show ads emphasize that the
filing cabinet will
anthropomorphize the filing
cabinet right.
As Lisa Gitelman points out, the
word automatic came into general
use in the 19th century derived
from what automatons sorry that
so that is that the increasing
use of automatic carried with
it, quote, lingering
connotations of resolving the
organic and the mechanical of
human forms and functions built
into machinery and of mechanical
responses by human beings. So as
a machine because that's how the
filing cabinet was often
marketed, it took on the work of
remembering, right, in her 1923
book Filing Department Operation
and Control Ethel Scholfield
argued that with the increased
scale and expectation of 20th
century corporate capitalism, an
individual businessmen could no
longer depend on his memory to
recall all aspects of his
business with the detail that
20th century capitalism
demanded. Scholfield noted that
replacing this memory quote
presupposes a thoroughgoing
automatic system for the
association of ideas, close
quote, posing the question, can
such a thing be secured? by
mechanical means she immediately
answers, experience tells us
Yes, therefore Scholfield calls
vehicle files and automatic
memory. Now automatic in this
case really does mean
predetermined, and taking on the
role of thinking of remembering
from people remembering where
information was located. Office
equipment identified as a
machine was understood to
guarantee order. This was
partitions and tabs, generating
granular certainty, which in the
name of efficiency, and saving
time, directed the user to where
the needed information could be
found in transitioning to the
second part of the talk
information labor. Now that user
was understood as someone who
operated a machine, hence the
importance of the hands of the
operator, the hands that had to
pick up and hold paper and
information. James McCord, who
founded the New York School of
Filing. Yes, they taught filing
in high schools, and they were
private schools in 1914. Used
his textbook to stress the need
for a clerk to possess physical
dexterity. I'm not going to read
the quote in full. But the point
here is that although the filing
cabinet lacked the mechanical
parts that underscored
scientific management
celebration of dexterity in the
factory, McCord's description
illustrates the importance of
hands and fingers to filing in
the office right filing demanded
more than the mere handling of
paper. It involves selecting
grasping, removing, lifting,
placing, fingering, drawing,
putting, right so fingers,
displaced objects and fingers
grasp and displace objects, they
isolate them and they gather
them together, they manipulate
and shape objects. So guided by
the intellect to the filing
cabinet, the hands of a file
clerk manipulated information,
not in the sense of falsifying
information, but in the sense of
handling it of moving
information within the office.
This is a period when the
concept of workflow emerges a
whole lot in the book about the
granular certainty that our
articulated information is a
discrete object via loose paper
also underwrote the labor of the
file clerk whose work enabled
its circulation and in fact the
file clerk emerges or as a
distinct occupational category
because the work of the 19th
century clerk, a man, was broken
down into a number of distinct
specialized tasks, including
typing, bookkeeping, and filing
to be done by a women. So filing
as an example, filing was an
example of clerical work that
emphasized the necessity of
particular bodies interacting
with a machine. The action of
these bodies was also separated
into discrete parts to better
manage the labor following the
logic of granular certainty. So
in the words of one filing menu,
author, mind, eye and hand can
soon be trained, so that they
automatically act together to do
the teamwork that is invaluable.
And the brain is part of this
team, but only because as labor
historian Harry Braverman
argues, to the extent that
clerical work, quote, is still
performed in the brain, the
brain is used as the equivalent
of the hand of the factory
worker in an assembly line. This
idea of filing is information
labor, I use information labor
to label office work, as it was
redefined as machine work. Now,
information labor is not a
distinct occupational category.
Rather, I used the term to refer
to a type of instrumental
encounter between workers and
information that became
increasingly common throughout
the 20th century and is still
with us in the 21st century. Its
ideal form, this is an encounter
that requires neither sought nor
interpretation, and does not
directly produce knowledge, a
product of discourses of system
and efficiency. It fits into a
conception of work that depends
on rational and calculated
procedures. So information work
is not knowledge work, and nor
is information work men's work.
This is very clear in the
advertisement that introduced
the filing cabinet and the work
associated with it. Gender
underwrote the distinction
between information, labor and
knowledge work in the office,
identifying it as woman's work
reinforced its secondary status.
Men could do these tasks, but
they were things that man AKA a
knowledge worker could do on the
side without any thought. A
catalog description for a so
called efficiency disk, which
included file drawers may
disappoint with the lack of
subtlety that is critical to the
genre of the trade catalogue.
Quote, each compartment should
represent a fixed place so that
the hand of the executive will
reach automatically for desired
records without interrupting the
continuity of brain action. In
this scenario, a man filed but
only while he thought about
something else. He reached over
to the drawer as a matter of
habit, where the file drawers
the machine worked to locate
information for him, a file
drawer remembered that allowed
the male executive to keep
thinking about matters deemed
productive. As an executive in
the gender office hierarchy, a
man was employed to think his
work was the priority of the
office. promotions for the
filing cabinet further
emphasized, it was designed as
an object to be used by women.
Some catalogs claimed that
women's bodies affected the
dimensions of the filing
cabinet. So the cabinet should
only be four drawers high
because quote that is about as
high as an ordinary girl can
work to advantage. Similarly, a
drawer was only 27 inches long,
because it could be pulled quote
by the file clerk as an arm
operation any longer it would
become a walking operation,
meaning the clerk would have to
move to the side of the drawer
to reach into the back. So
therefore, in case you have been
wondering all your life, what is
the vanishing point of utility,
the vanishing point of utility
is very close to 27 inches, it's
not 27 inches, but it's very,
very close. In another type of
ad, manufacturers sometimes used
a close-up of the interior of a
file drawer to illustrate how a
cabinet worked, so they could
claim their folders guides and
tabs and follow up blocks as
unique. And in these ads a
woman's body disappeared, though
her arms and hands might remain,
and in this example she is
literally erased from the image.
Now why the close-up of the
drawer was arguably necessary to
show the guides and tabs, the
fact they removed the body from
the image mean that the pair of
disembodied but gendered arms
and hands not only pointed out
the cabinet logic of the
interior of the drawer, but also
shows us show us the ideal
relationship between labor and
technology necessary for the
cabinet to be labeled automatic.
Hands or arms separated from
their bodies and minds suggested
that the user the users of this
office equipment did not have to
think as they worked, therefore,
disembodied hands in filing
advertisement represented work
that was neither independent nor
constructive. As Janet Zandy
argues quote, truncated hands
represent metonymically an
ignored whole or lesser human
element and species. Since the
17th century, this truncation
has been applied to workers
whether identified as hired
hands, or simply hands. And in
filing information labor. It was
only natural in this period that
these hands would belong to
woman. Advocates invoked as
common sense an association
between a woman's hands and
dexterity to naturalize the
construction of the new
machine-based information work,
or sorrym to naturalize the new
machine based information work
as feminine occupations. By 1943
Evelyn Steele, editorial
director of vocational guidance
research, could confidently note
quote, It is generally agreed
that women do well at
painstaking tedious work
requiring patience and dexterity
of the hands. The actual fact
that woman's fingers are more
slender than means makes a
difference, close quote. And
this idea was usually linked to
to work and leisure activities
the former invoke woman's work
and light manufacturing or
textiles. For the latter, it was
often noted that socially
acceptable leisure practices
provided ways for women to
enhance their apparent natural
dexterity, and thus gain in
formal training and filing. As
one manager commented, I often
ask a girl if she plays the
piano, or she knits, crochets,
sews or does another type of
work that would enable her to
acquire speed with her fingers.
Shockingly, despite this natural
connection between feminine
hands and hands and files,
sometimes the automatic memory
of the filing cabinet failed.
When it did those hands were
explicitly reconnected to a
body. Misfiling was the fault of
the file clerk, never the filing
cabinet or the filing system.
Oops.
As the mode of misuse and error
misfiring is what Victoria
Olwell calls a bodily
malfunction. That is the cloak
of invisibility covering the
body drops away, the moment the
body makes a mistake. So
misfiling makes visible a very
particular body, that of a young
woman. As one company magazine
asked can Miss File misfile?
The answer was yes. And it was
due to her youth and her Miss
unmarried status. This was the
very same youth however, that
was of course critical to her
efficiency, or at least the cost
efficiency of her labor. The
work of file clerks was
efficient in part because
dominant beliefs about gender
and sexuality lowered its cost.
File clerks were poorly paid not
only because they were women and
young, but also because they
were unmarried. What Mar Hicks
calls, quote, an assumed
heteronormativity created a
family wage and an informal
marriage bar. That is a young
woman was never assumed to be a
household's main breadwinner, so
it didn't matter what you paid
her. And once married, she would
of course, stop working at the
office either by choice or force
and go and stay home and look
after a husband and the kids
that will inevitably follow. So
this unmarried status and the
assumption that all women wanted
to marry men was viewed as the
immediate cause of filing. So
from this perspective, unmarried
women who worked close to me and
could be distracted while they
thought about potential husbands
around them. Surveys of woman
office workers did support the
belief that marriage was a
priority for young women who
worked in offices, but it is not
clear if it dictated the actions
in the office. Assuming that
marriage dominated thoughts of
female clerks, work advice
literature focused on managing
female desire, unwanted sexual
advances and harrassment from me
and when not behaviors to be
managed or even publicly
discussed. It was the
responsibility of woman to keep
their emotions and quote, the
feminine instinct to attract to
awaken her response, close
quote, in a space where is the
male manager of an employment
service, possibly this guy in
the photo here put it, women
were hired to quote, add to the
general attractiveness of the
office and experienced female
office manager instructed file
clerks, quote, to leave fine
clothes, the theater, pleasant
parties, and Tom, Dick, and
Harry at home, which also raises
the idea that our clerks are
quite [...], I think with Tom,
Dick and Harry with them. This
was necessary because if a woman
brought such thoughts into the
office, it would break down the
teamwork of senses and the mind.
Quote, as she says here,
important tasks cannot be
accomplished with your hands.
While unimportant details fill
your head, you cannot fall
amusement under work, they are
at the extremes of the alphabet,
she must be very proud of that
line. Thus, Miss File would
misfile if she failed to
compartmentalize, if she failed
to keep her personal concerns
and work duties in the proper
place and order. That is the
explanation for her behavior
invoke the very act of misfile,
right of putting something in
the wrong place. Perhaps it's
not surprising that the filing
cabinet was offered as a tool to
teach young women to better
order their lives by controlling
their thoughts and desires,
especially when these women were
often the daughters of
immigrants working in a space
coded as middle class. An office
manager argued that office
technologies would teach these
young woman quote, the three
necessities of efficiency:
concentration, accuracy, and
good nature. She explained
concentration as the need to
control your thoughts as you
must your pencil with a firm
grip despite outside
disturbance, and inward
annoyance. I think we've all
felt that. However, it was not
only office technologies, like
the pencil and the filing
cabinet that could teach woman
the necessity of efficiency.
When a woman left the office as
apparently she would become a
wife and mother, she used new
domestic storage technologies
that reinforced the value of
productivity and efficiency. In
the 1920s, storage in the home
changed dramatically. Prior to
this storage spaces were not
factored into the design of
houses. So for example, closets
and cabinets were not designed
to store specific objects. This
changed as the cabinet logic of
designated places and petitions
and office furniture became
critical to how spaces were
managed and objects stored in
the home. This was seen for
example, in response to the
early 20th century closet
problem. Previously
afterthoughts or a little more
than wall cavities, closets
became purpose built, they will
organize. The enclosed spaces of
closets will organize into
smaller spaces just think Ikea
catalog, right? However, the
main action in terms of home
storage was in the kitchen, as
kitchen design became a thing
that filled the pages of House
and Garden, House Beautiful,
Ladies Home Journal etc. It
began with standalone cabinets
that turned kitchen storage into
the strategic use of shelves,
drawers and partitions. In this
way the modern kitchen was
linked to the office through a
faith in a cabinet logic that
prioritized meticulously
organized interior storage to
make things accessible. This was
captured in the Hoosier cabinet,
six foot high and four feet
wide. Its large shelves and
drawers held such items as pans,
kettles and nested mixing bowls
all in specially designed
spaces. promotional materials
claim that a Hoosier Cabinet had
400 articles all within an arm's
reach. Manufacturers and writers
were keen to acknowledge the
debt to the office vertical or
upright petitions called files
were added shelves we still see
them sometimes today that allows
plates and platters to be stored
on its edge quote, you can pick
out with one hand just the dish
that you want. Ads to be
expected were much more succinct
the business of getting meals.
The kitchen needs to be
businesslike and in this ad, we
can see a little cutout of an
office with a filing cabinet and
with the vertical verticality of
the skyscraper as well. Now as
implied when announcing the move
from the office to the home,
what I see important in these
changes in home storage is that
they illustrate that storage
technologies require a certain
form of labor performed by a
particular worker. Storage is
not neutral. An encounter with
these technologies encourage
women to understand their self
worth through productivity. As
the interaction between hand and
object became the representation
of efficient labor in the home,
these economic values became a
way to express identity.
Addressed in these way, these
women participated in a
reconfiguration of attitudes
towards self and work
performance that helped make
productivity common sense. And
adjustment that Mel Gregg argues
gives productivity it's 20th
century history. I want to go
further and link these changes
to information right to say
although changes in domestic
storage did not address
information as a formal
category, they do offer a
suggestive example of how people
experience modern information
via the materiality of storage
technologies. Right. So granular
certainty, cabinet logic moved
to the house and brought with it
a particular form of work
centered on an idea of the
particular and the specific. By
way of conclusion, I want to
restate some key arguments by
briefly discussing two of my
favorite research discoveries
that I couldn't fit in the in
the paper earlier. Now the first
is a trade catalog from a
Michigan based company called
Shaw Walker. In the early 20th
century, they advertise their
filing equipment under the
slogan built like a skyscraper.
I can explain later what that
means, if you really curious,
the camp a campaign. The reason
I'm interested in this is this
campaign places filing at the
center of the gender division of
the modern office, albeit from
the perspective of the male. The
built like a skyscraper campaign
constructed a series of physical
encounters between male and
female bodies in the company's
filing cabinets to illustrate
different aspects of the
essentials of office equipment,
strength, rigidity, easy
operation, noiselessness,
economy of floor space, maximum
capacity and good design.
Because we always think of good
design when we look at a filing
cabinet. So it shows men jumping
into open drawers, lifting their
bodies off the ground, and
hanging from open drawers, what
the catalog calls handstands.
The letter image we use to
signify the rigidity of the
drawers as opposed to the
strength of the drawers
illustrated by men jumping into
them. I'm going to come back to
this but I shouldn't say other
companies did something similar
using photographs of men sitting
or standing, and the open
drawers or the filing cabinets.
The point of this was
purportedly to show that a
filing cabinet was built to hold
the weight of paper because four
drawers, each drawer weighing 75
pounds is really is a lot is a
lot of weight. And you want to
know that not only will the
filing cabinet fall apart, but
the drawer can open smoothly in
the little girl down the bottom
there. But I would suggest the
filing the built like a
skyscraper campaign is not
subtle at all in the ways that
it represented these issues
right? It doesn't take much I
think for anyone armed with some
basic theories of gender
representation to argue that as
brief exercise routine, and the
advertisement seem to reflect
the anxiety that men felt about
the arrival of woman clerical
workers in offices, the phallic
skyscraper, the unsheathed tip
of the Woolworth building in the
background there rigid and erect
male lytic body also I would
suggest humbly to make explicit
the masculinity of the men who
worked in the office. Such
masculinity was not to be
questioned. This is reinforced
by the image the campaign uses
to demonstrate the easy
operation of the filing cabinet
where not only do they chose to
choose a woman or a female body
to open the file drawer, they
choose a child they choose a job
child pulling on a silk thread.
The idea being here that I think
you know if a child can do it,
anyone could operate a filing
cabinet if anyone can file a
filing requires any the strength
and the intellect have a go,
then only women should file
because men can do other work
that women can't do. The second
find I want to finish with is a
nationally syndicated cartoon
from 1921 reprinted and
Heather's favorite magazine
Filing that ran for four years
as part of a failed attempt to
get filing recognized as a
profession. The cartoon in a
very odd way can be used to
illustrate the effects of
capitalism on information or
rather the changing shape of
capitalism on information. So in
it we see here a male file clerk
quits after his boss refuses to
increase his pay before he
leaves in an act of defiance. He
removes the papers from the
filing cabinet and throws them
around the office and the final
two panels the boss changes his
mind And the clerk gets the news
of his pay increase was
surrounded by loose papers and
files. This image stood out to
me when I found it because when
the boss makes the decision to
increase the file clicks pay, he
calls them Mr. Google. Right?
And then the coincidence of the
name Google being associated
with access to information is
pretty uncanny. Which and it
became basically ridiculous.
When it's digit. The image
itself, as we can see, is
digitized by Google, right. So
yes, this borders on the
ridiculous this coincidence, but
I also find it a useful way to
illustrate that categories of
information overload and
information management take
vastly different forms at
different historical moments. At
one time, as I've argued, the
filing cabinet was the symbol of
orderly information management.
By the end of the 20th century,
Google Search has taken that
mantle. In the comic strip, Mr.
Google sabotages the filing
system right by spilling papers
out of their proper locations.
Ironically, this results in
exactly the kind of giant pile
of papers ie the web made up of
pages that Google, th
corporation is now technically
Alphabet, but that ruins my
point here. Google, the
corporation provides access to
through PageRank. The chaos Mr.
Google creates is exactly the
chaos that Google later on
promises to manage. That is,
although different, both the
filing cabinet and the search
engine became organizing
principles for the capitalist
management of information. And I
will stop.
Heather Hendershot: About filing
magazine, I just started one
question on which is a filing
cabinet makes this emergence in
1890s. At the same time that
[...] telephones phones,
elevators, typewriters, like all
the machinery and modern offices
are happening at once and you
think, is there a connection
across these machines that you
think is important? Or is the
filing cabinet, a Hoover machine
or he system of that moment, the
most important one, and the
others are sort of
Craig Robertson: I think there
were connections, and there are
things that make the filing
cabinet, unique. So I think the
connection between all of those
things is that the operation of
those machines is what I call
information labor. Right? So
this is this moment in which
this, this, this very sort of
instrumental encounter or
interaction with information
comes to define work. And you
don't have to necessarily, like
understand that the context or
mean or the content of what
you're doing, you just help
things information circle, I
think that connects them. And so
next in some implicitly argue
that they're all, they're all
connected, they're all in some
way, making manifest a
particular idea of information
distinct from knowledge, what
makes the filing cabinet a
particularly useful example of
that moment, is the way in which
it allows us to really
understand the sense of
information, right, in such a
significant way that the filing
cabinet, the files, the tabs,
the manila folders continue, as
I said, at the beginning of the
talk to sort of these the ways
in which we're asked to think
about our encounters with
information. So that to me, is
what the the way the filing
cabinet kind of stands out. And
I think it is important. I mean,
the filing cabinet is arguably
more important if we think about
storage and the value of
storage, because that's where
information is stored, right?
Like the filing cabinet becomes
absolutely absolutely critical
infrastructure to allow, like
the, to allow the modern world
to function. Right? Like it's
critical to governance, it's
critical to corporations, right?
Because that's how information
is stored and retrieved. And you
know, if if there was another
technology that did that, then I
probably would have written
about that, in one sense, but
the filing cabinet did. And of
course, like all infrastructure,
it's kind of weird, but it's
just in the corner. And the
labor associated with
Heather Hendershot: that started
starts me so fascinating. Oh,
yeah, that paper is like a
filing cabinet and the files the
people and you need that, you
know that you know, you need the
elevators to get people to the
20th floor so they can work so
they can go in their slots for
all their whatever be in their
spot, afternoon.
Craig Robertson: Yeah, exactly.
And that's what I mean, like the
fifth chapter of the book after
the introduction is called
Verticality, and it explores all
those connections, right. And in
fact, to the point that I sort
of argue that when capitalism
takes on its 20th century [...],
it has a vertical bias, right?
You know, and I think we can see
that in all the things that that
you mentioned, like the
skyscraper here that I've put up
on the screen and and the
elevator, but also thinking
about with the filing cabinet,
but also thinking about
managers. hierarchy, right, the
vertical ladder, like, you know,
verticality, I really do think
it has a vertical bias until the
network arguably comes in as a
hurry. Oh
Heather Hendershot: literalized
various men, and she moves up in
the building your camera shows
outside the building goes up.
It's amazing. I will stop
monopolizing here
Craig Robertson: No, no, all
right, no, yeah, yeah.
Heather Hendershot: And then we
have some queues,
people queued up in our q&a as
well.
Srushti Kamat: Hi. Um, so I want
to talk a bit about the haptic
element or [...] of touch sort
of storage in touch and how
they're related, and kind of
bringing it to contemporary
storage of the cloud and the
dry, and the sort of ethereality
of that right, the non existence
of a touch, but in fact, there
are other drives, right, that,
you know, contain the data. I
guess, I wonder, like, do you
see the non, like verticality of
contemporary [...] See
contemporary storage practices
not have to once? I mean, do you
see them as changing this, this
this kind of vertical capitalism
or not?
Craig Robertson: Yeah, I think
that, um, I always, I always
have to, you know, begin
hesitantly begin these, these
questions, because I, you know,
I am an historian by training,
right. So, like, I, obviously, I
think about, and I come to this
through contemporary questions
and issues, but it's not, it's
not when my head fully goes. So
yeah, part of the thing of kind
of the point I want to talk
about here is that when I'm
arguing that storage is not
neutral, in the ways that you
just talked about contemporary
storage not being neutral, it
speaks to, you know, like
different values, or different
ways in which storage has been
defined. Right. So the notion of
verticality, I think is
absolutely central to how
storage is understood within the
context of capitalism, right, in
the early 20th century, I think
as capitalism changes, and I
sort of, you know, just when I
was talking to the responding to
Heather's point, you know,
saying that, like, in the middle
of the 20th century of the
second half of the 20th century,
the network, we can argue
becomes important, and then you
can think about a horizontal
bias, you know, and then, you
know, and then, you know, the
cloud, you know, and then we can
think about concepts of the
cloud and that less tangible
understanding of storage is
another further development
initially, I think it really
affects how we think about
storage, right? If because the
things aren't piling up, then
you know, you don't turn around
and have an entire wall of CDs,
or an entire wall of records,
right. And so, so that lack of
like that, the, the lessening of
that haptic dimension, to that
individual specific item of
storage, I think completely
alters how we think about
storage, right, it makes storage
live in a way that the filing
cabinet, you know, is not at
all, but I think you noted this,
too, but there's still we can't
deny the haptic dimension that
is still the, you know, in terms
of how we how we access things,
but yeah, so So definitely, I
mean, I think these are issues
and part of what I always, you
know, every story is hope,
right? Is that people who are
much more invested in
contemporary issues can take
some of the concepts that
history have allowed us as
historians to think about, and
you know, and apply them, you
know, and really develop them.
Yeah, I could go on with that.
And I may, if there are no
Kurt Fendt: I have a question
that I missed the first couple
of minutes. Oh, yeah. So, you
know, I was wondering, was there
a specific company behind
promoting those? Because, you
know, it's connected to my real
question is to what extent that
system of the vertical filing
the filing cabinet also
translated to other countries,
right. It has to do of course,
with that capitalistic idea of
company, you know, promoting
those those ideas in terms of
frequency answer.
Craig Robertson: Sure. Yeah. So
so that is an American
invention, right? It comes out
through the 1890s. There's not
really one, there's not you
know, it's it's very much of its
time, so there wasn't really one
inventor, per se, though, if you
go to Wikipedia, there's a nice
invention story for you. And it
is actually kind of appealing
because they credited the
company they credited to is a
company called the Library
Bureau, which was founded by
Melville Dewey of the Dewey
Decimal System, right? Even
though he was no longer part of
the company, when they were when
when they're attributed with
inventing the filing cabinet. It
also links it to the library and
the card catalog and all those
things. So you have to the
filing cabinet really does take
off as an American product and
builds this office equipment
company, office equipment
industry, most of the companies
are based either in the Midwest
or in upstate New York for for a
variety of reasons, by the
1920s, the vertical filing
cabinet is starting to be
exported. Right. And it has an
impact in Europe. But, you know,
you lived in Europe, you know
that the vertical file there is
not the vertical filing cabinet.
Right. It's the arch binder,
right. And that's the arch
binder that in some ways,
Cornelia Viesmann and her
canonical book Files, which is
sort of a media archaeology of
the legal file, like she talks
about vertical files, and that
but they're the binders, right?
So I have not explored and I'm
not going to play with
stereotypes to you know, to, you
know, to figure out why it is in
in, in many countries, the file
remains that binder concept is
the if that was part of your
question, I I definitely
absolutely acknowledged that
distinction. Yeah. Maybe it's
the lack of skyscrapers. Is
there another question over
there? Yeah. Hi.
G. R. Marvez: So I know that
like modern filing cabinets have
the safety feature we can't open
the doors at once did that like
start when it was first
invented? Or like that come
later?
Craig Robertson: Yeah, that's
that's a great question about
sort of security and privacy
right which of course is another
important key aspect of storage
often so what the initial
initial filing cabinets didn't
come with locks and this was a
concern about security locks
came in but it was it was it was
just simply a lock that locked
all for you that locked door for
drawers right um, and it's Yeah,
with sorry with that what you
were asking what when they you
can only pull out one at a time
or
G. R. Marvez: when you open
multiple drawers you risk
toppling?
Craig Robertson: Oh, sorry.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah. So did not
have that mechanism. Sorry. I
missed I missed that. Yeah. So
it had a lock to lock for, to
lock for drawers. But now it's
well into the 20, middle of the
20th century, when you develop
the mechanism to stop the more
coming out and so there is that
concern, right of them toppling
over? Which is part of what
those guys doing their their
handstands, right, you know, and
pull ups on the jumping into the
filing cabinet is meant to say,
hey, you know, look, this
drawing of a man, you know,
shows that all these photographs
of these people sitting in show
that it can take this weight and
it's not sorry, it's not going
to tip over there was that that
I get to it eventually or with?
Andrew Whitacre: Someone with
one word, maybe you can question
from Aguinaldo Melo. Professor
Craig, can you cite one example
with partiality that you found
Heather Hendershot: practicality
Craig Robertson: partiality,
looking at a nation stored as an
example partially sorry, I I'm a
little lost on that question.
Can we? Yeah, I haven't had
another word to that. Bias. I
know like it's there. But ah, so
ah, so okay, I'll keep going.
Yep. Okay, thank you. Thank you.
Okay. Bias is that you found in
looking? Okay. Maybe Maybe I
kind of spoke to too loosely in
the tour. Maybe this is where
this question came from? I think
so. Yes. I mean, cost the
information within the file,
that sort of file cabinets can
represent multiple biases,
right? The the argument about
information being objective,
right, is that information is
something that can exist
separate from the context in
which it's created. So that it
can be interpreted very easily,
right. So this idea of
information is something
different from knowledge is
information having is having
sort of affectivity, right,
like, so it's not data, but it
has affectivity. So I was
talking when I was talking about
it being objective, I was
talking about the conception of
information, right, as an entity
as a thing, not the actual, if
you like, stuff on the piece of
paper. does. Does that make
sense? I mean, I don't know if
that makes sense. So So yeah,
there's a lot of bias in it
within the information within
the files and folders
themselves. I'm just gonna keep
moving through images. So
they're
Srushti Kamat: actually kind of
origin of information. Should
you expand on that? Where did
you go to find that origin of
information as a concept?
Craig Robertson: Right, so I'm
drawing pretty heavily on the
work of Geoff Nunberg. It's an
essay called farewell to the
information age, and a book, he
co edited with Paul Duguid, I
think called the future the book
that came out in the early
1990s. Right. And it says
beautifully written essay that
is incredibly smart and has
shaped a lot of the work in
media studies. But the work of
people looking at the
intersection of paper and
information, so someone like
Lisa Gitelman, for example. And
so, yes, and so Nunberg is
arguing that in this period, as
I think I mentioned, very
quickly in the talk, in the 19th
century, information moves from
being a process, right, being
informed being educated to being
a thing to being something that
you can possess. And that is
that it's something that can
exist, or that is an entity. And
there's also a special issue of
the journal history of human
sciences, I think, which goes
through and talks about the
development of the 19th century
of the idea of data through the
uses of the way in which sits
the census in Europe in the
United States comes to be
represented. So again, you've
got tables, right, that are all
representing information, you
know, as something that is
discrete, right, that has,
therefore some kind of presence
in the world, right. And as
understood that the idea is that
you can look at the stuff at a
glance, right meaning you, as
it's John Seely Brown and Paul
Duguid put it like, you know,
knowledge needs a knower. Right,
it needs a subject that needs a
person. But information doesn't
have a knower. Right, it doesn't
have a purpose, you know, it's
understood to be this thing that
exists in the world. And so what
I find fascinating about the
filing cabinet, is that through
the concept of the file, this
kind of sort of abstract
understanding of information is
something distinct from
knowledge that's starting to
percolate through society, from
the middle of the 19th century
on, suddenly, there's a tangible
way you can conceive of it,
right, because now you have this
loose piece of paper, you know,
in a in a file folder in a
drawer, and you can extract this
one piece of paper versus having
to get the entire, you know, big
bound book, and have to look
through it and scroll through
it. So that it's that idea of
the particularity of paper, I
think helps underscore this
notion of information as a
discrete unit. Now, I'm pushing
it a bit further with the file
cabinet. But other people have
made, you know, a similar
argument in that sense. And I
think it's a really attractive
and appealing argument. And for
me, what I find particularly
fascinating is in this period,
as I read, through the
literature, the word information
is being used, but so is
knowledge. And so is data and
that, and it might be like
instrumental knowledge or
structured knowledge or
organized knowledge, there's
just the struggle, people are
fumbling around to try and name
something that's new. That's the
way I read it, right? And so,
and then information becomes the
thing, you know, that that is
the name for that kind of
specificity, that isn't
numerical, right? That isn't
data. So data takes on that in
the early 20th century, takes on
on that name. And so, you know,
like no one in the early 20th
century is saying they're living
in an information age or an
information society. But again,
I think, you know, part of the
way I locate the book is in what
I call the genealogy of the
ascendance of modern
information. Right. So this is a
very particular mark, period,
and an important period in that
moment, before we go to, you
know, to to the middle of the
20th century, you know, and
information becomes, you know,
information becomes, I can't
think of anyone's names, you
know, MIT guys, I'm completely
blanking, you know, where
information becomes something
that you? Yes, yes, these
massive, huge figures where
information becomes something
that you can measure. And that's
another form a technical form of
information, which is also part
of the story. But I think this
proceeding, that is an important
part of the story, just to be
able to think about information
as a unit, even if that unit
becomes something different,
because of the work that happens
around here.
Tomás Guarna: [...]
Craig Robertson: Yeah. So I
mean, so the card catalog,
right? Becomes is key to that.
Right? And, and businesses a
using card like that, you know,
businesses still use the
equivalent of a library card
catalog, often to record the
ledger, the bound book ledger
can become a card ledger, right.
I mean, there are many ways in
which you know, the cabinet
comes in the card, catalog
cabinet or versions of it come
into the office. So that's the I
think that's the other really
main sort of competing thing.
The punch card, right is the
other one, right? But punch
cards in this period that really
not in a lot of businesses
compared to the filing cabinet
and the card catalog, but yes,
those mean those I think Those
are two other few, like
competing ways of, of, of
conceit of thinking about this
conception of information. But
they definitely don't have the
sort of uptake that the filing
cabinet does. And then of
course, what makes the filing
cabinet interesting looking
back, is the fact that files and
tabs etc, are how we still think
about information, we don't
think about the card, right? You
know, like Scrivener might want
us to go back and think about,
you know, the card, but we don't
think about a card or a catalog
in that way. And the punch card,
you know, like, whereas we do
think about the file, you know,
in multiple ways, both as the
icon on our desktop, but also
the directory system, right? And
again, Vismann's book File. It's
only if you I don't read German
well enough to read the German,
the longer version where I think
she expands a little bit more on
this. But an English translation
is just a very short nod to the
current moment. But she really
traces a history through legal
records in the registry of the
idea of the file in terms of
directory nesting structure,
where instead of I'm looking via
the filing cabinet, more is the
file is icon on the desktop,
right? And folder on the
desktop. So yeah.
Heather Hendershot: Could you
talk more about the gender as a
project display feminine a
female sexuality as a problem.
You referenced, you know,
unwanted advances, yes, sort of
an issue. But also you said they
were undiscussed in a way. So
there's the problem that a woman
naturally brings this sort of
threat because she's, she's
feminine and irresistible, and
he brings it to the office and
has to be managed. But it
doesn't seem to be. They're
trying, it feels like trying to
downplay that. Because if you
open that up, it becomes too
much or too dangerous. And I'm
thinking, I'm just wondering how
much there is ambivalence there.
But as I nearly started
thinking, once again, but
Hollywood films and specifically
from like the 1929 to 33 period
before the production code,
where you do have films like
baby doll that I reference where
the woman who is the secretary
who files [...], whatever, is
inherently a sexual threat a
sexual danger in the workplace,
then you have quite a few films
that are ambivalent. And really,
it has to do with like, how you
script the film, the media, that
sort of bad girl, the engenue,
right. And so the film
Skyscraper Souls is like the
perfect example of this right?
It starred Warren William the
ultimate cad this boss figure of
these are movies, right? Who,
you know, you have the secretary
struggling not to be raped, and
then you have the old hands been
through several bosses and part
of the job, you know, it's her
that's raped, and the film
acknowledges it as horrific.
There's just a sort of
fascinating ambivalence about
women, in these corporate
workplaces that you see in
popular culture, and I'm just
curious, how much of that really
comes through in all the
interesting sources?
Craig Robertson: Yes. So, so,
that so my comments are about
sort of the about the
harrassment you know, which you
know, the this image here right
of this creepy guy just staring
at this woman in here, she
refusing to make this is an ad
to make you want to buy a filing
cabinet right, like so, but a
lot, but a lot of that stuff
draws from secondary sources
right. So, which you may or may
not be familiar with. Lisa Fine
wrote a book which looks at and
analyzes all of these films and
other popular cultural artifacts
at the time, Sharon Strom is
where I took a lot the comment
about about not discuss like
being acknowledged, but not
discussing the behavior of men.
And so in the, in the sources
that I found, so I was looking
at vocational sources, right. So
vocational literature, and all
the How to Office manuals, and
all this all the literature that
was out there to recruit women
into the office and in that
there was no ambivalence, right?
Like, you know, the
responsibility was squarely on
the shoulders of women to behave
themselves and as I said,
they're quite like you know, to
check their apparently you know,
natural desire to throw
themselves if you know at any
man and this was fought through
clothes, right that's what like
so what clothes were acceptable
to be worn in and worn in the
office right and that was in
that quote about as well as
leaving Tom, Dick, and Harry at
home you left all your fancy
clothes at home right? And so
that becomes a site where people
Yeah, a site of struggle over
where it seems that female
workers are trying to express
some sense of themselves through
the through the sexuality right
but um, but yeah, I didn't see I
did not find that ambivalence
that that you can't You're right
that is there and in my and you
know, in my limited endings of
those films and that sort of
whole sub genre of the office
wife. Right, which, you know, is
in fact, one, I think called the
office wife. And then there are
the, you know, that's a
recurring character, right. We,
you know, she is the threat in
the sense, you know, like she is
she's become his wife in the
office, right. It's not, you
know, it's not my office buddy.
kind of joking thing. But you
know, today, but it's my office
wife.
Heather Hendershot: I mean, and
this is, of course, where it's
like a period, but The Apartment
is exactly what you're talking
about, or what we're talking
about here with the gender
issues of the boss, Secretary
Secretary. Yeah. And then, you
know, that secretary becomes the
wife slot, and they need a new
secretary, to be the office
wife, like, yeah, so and so.
[...].
Craig Robertson: Yeah, yeah. No,
so there's a lot of dynamic and
there, it's a really smart
histories of, of, essentially,
the history of, you know, sexual
harassment in the office, right,
in the modern office, that had
been written, coming largely
coming out of lit out of English
literature, but but really
interesting ways where people
have explored this, you know,
and, and like I say, to me, in
terms of that literature, this
makes a very small contribution
by just saying, well, in this
vocational literature, we can
see this is going on, right. And
I think there is some connection
to the mode of work, that women
are doing the office.
The filing was a magazine
published for four years that
it's published, it's all on
Google. It's what you can, it's
all on Google Books. And it's
all been scanned. And it ran for
four years, and it really was
part of an attempt to
professionalize filing. So
librarianship had just been
professionalized. Archivist work
was about to be
professionalized. And so people
wanted filing to be
professionalized. And that's
what this magazine pushed. They
were filing associations founded
in major cities, generally, in
the Northeast that had monthly
meetings, maybe 100, people
would show up, maybe 20 people
would show up, a guest person
would go and deliver the talk on
this is how we file and, you
know, in the insurance company I
work for, you know, this is how
we file in this church, right?
You know, and they would meet
once a month and have a little
chat. And, you know, and so
that's, you know, and so that's
where their magazine came from,
but it's all up here, if you
want to read and it just, you
know, it's a clearinghouse for
information about how to file.
And, sadly, I thought it would
play a bigger part in the book,
but it's there, when I talk
about this failed campaign to
professionalize.
Unknown: Were their special
training programs, because you
mentioned that there's a new
profession emerging.
Craig Robertson: Yes. Yes. So
there's some. So there's, so it
fails, right? But but they are
trying to teach filing, right.
And so they're the, the office
equipment companies create
different ways to teach filing.
So this is from Lowell High
School, just up the road in
1923. And they're using Library
Bureau equipment. And what the
Library Bureau did, which is
really radical, right, is that
they reduced, right, letters
down to the small sizes, right?
So you would then file them in
these boxes, because the problem
was, it was really hard to teach
filing, because filing cabinets
took up so much space, and you'd
have to line up to take your
turn file the letter, right. And
so they would the office
equipment companies constructed
this, these courses right there
could run from 24 classes, up to
72 or 96, class one hour classes
in filing. Now, I didn't find
any school or even any private
school that took up 96 lessons,
but they would incorporate the
lessons into into the commercial
education courses that girls
were being channeled into.
Because this is also a period
like in the beginning of the
20th century, I think it's 5% of
American teenagers go to high
school. So there's this
concerted effort to get kids
into high school. And so this is
where vocation education emerges
as as something that's taught in
high schools. So filing comes in
as in as part of that, right.
And this is also I found, just
as an aside complaints from
English professors and so forth,
that they were being forced to
teach technical writing, and all
the stuff that we maybe think of
as a late ninth, late 20th
century, early 21st century
problem was a consequence of the
success of bringing in
vocational education. So by the
1930s pushed along, no doubt by
the Depression, about like 70
70% of teenagers are in high
school.
Heather Hendershot: If I'm
correct in recalling that this
is the same moment that home
economics as a field was
invented.
Craig Robertson: Right, wow.
Really, but again, it takes off
right but it says same thing
about how can we keep people in
high school, like we want them
in high school and of course
what happened? As the business
community, shockingly, takes
over the conversation and pushes
it to a lot of commercial
education, but women do filing
and typing, and boy, sorry girls
do woman filing and typing and
boys do accounting and
management, you know, program
management courses, and things
like this, right? So yeah, these
are, again is a, this is a
manual for teachers, right. And
the bottom one, these are the
letters. And the thing is the
letters can be filed in
different ways, depending if
it's subject filing, geographic
filing, alphabetical name
filing, right. And so it's
again, teaching their kids to
very quickly look, they're
taught to read very quickly,
right, they call it like the
dictionary or the direct
telephone directory, this is
where you just look for the
first three letters of the last
name to know where it's going to
go. Right. You don't have to
read the whole thing again,
don't need to know, right,
you're you're it's this form of
information labor. I could go on
for hours.
Heather Hendershot: The ways
that we find resonance with
contemporary issues and the way
things have bounced back and
forth. And, you know, I'm
thinking about big data and our
sense that now we have too much
data. We didn't used to have too
much data, but now it's too much
data. And the
Craig Robertson: Big paper, big
paper, they're a big paper.
Heather Hendershot: This is
like, there's just too much. I
mean, there's too much
information, you need to file 40
files in 60 seconds or whatever.
Yeah, or one minute, whatever it
is, it's because they're just
infathomable amount of
information.
Craig Robertson: Yeah no, it
definitely is like it's a it's a
moment of information overload,
right? You know, and that's what
I like about the Google comic
strip, like these different
modes of information overload.
But I feel this is a really, you
can call this information
overload, because it's
understood, it's what's being
overloaded is understood as
information, not paper, right?
It's called that. But if people
talk about information overload
prior to that, they may be
talking in like, it's
overwhelming amount of
knowledge, but it's literally
not called information by the
contemporary actors, right. And
so I think this is a real
important example, you know, an
early form, you're completely
right of information overload.
And the filing cabinet seeks to
manage that, you know, and you
know, and again, it comes up
with this conception, what the
filing cabinet doesn't, but what
emerges is a conception of
information akin to data, like,
you know, let's remove it from
context. So we can better do
something with it. So let's
remove it from the context of a
bound volume of 19, you know, of
the correspondence from the
Madrid office of, you know, of
the US Embassy, you know, where
there might be passport stuff in
the middle of it, but it's all
bound in this big book. But now
we can isolate it is these
discrete things, we don't need
to understand the context of
what's going on in Madrid, in
the Madrid office to understand
this thing about the filing
about the passport. But the
implication is we did when it
was a bound volume. I know I
kind of lost your [...]
Unknown: I'm also wondering if
you looked at sort of power as
it's coated in these in the
files themselves, in the
systems, I asked that, because I
guess the early 20th century is
still like a colonial
colonialism. Right? So I am
talking about information
overload, but there's also
information access as it's
opened up to a lot more people.
And then also there's fears of
bias and algorithms. I mean, we
could go Yeah, not so much about
it. So I'm wondering, like, Are
there are there ways that the
cabinet functioned visit
exclusive space just to hold
information only accessible to
specific people? And other you
know, what I mean, other ways we
can understand that exclusivity
differently?
Craig Robertson: Yeah, yeah,
that's a great question. And I,
I was kind of surprised by that.
Because I, you know, I have, for
another set of reasons, I have a
lot of interest in the way in
which the archive has been
thought about, particularly by
historians of the British
Empire, right, you know, and,
and, you know, and other people,
like thinking of [...], and so
forth, but particularly within
the British Empire, and, and,
you know, through the 19th
century, again, it's towards the
end of the 19th century, that it
but there's a more systematic
way to organize the records of
the British Empire, because
prior to that, literally just
piles of paper dumped somewhere,
as these reports that these poor
colonial official has been
forever crafting, just get
arrived in London and just get
put in a pile. Right. So I was
expecting and maybe thinking
that I would find something, you
know, something connected to
that to the very question you're
asking, but in the literature
that I was looking at, I didn't
find it. Now. You know, I'm not
writing a history of
classification. I am writing
history of storage. So so that
negates a part of what you said,
but still, where you ended up.
The final point of your
question, I think is really
important. And so, you know, I
found you know, the closest I
got was just finding, you know,
debates and concerns about
security and privacy, just sort
of in general, right. Within an
office so right to a filing
cabinet. There was discussions
of private filing, you know, the
private filing cabinet of a man
in his office separate from the
larger filing cabinets of you
know, the battery, or as they
call them, you know, the dozens
of filing cabinets that occupied
the center space, you know, of
an office. Right? But yes,
surprisingly, and it's not to
say it's not there, it just
wasn't there in the literature
that I that I was looking at,
but I think, you know, it is a
it is a really, really important
question about like, how the
filing cabinet as a mode of
storage is understood to
exclude, right, you know, in
terms of the, like, access and
type of knowledge, right,
because these women have all
this, this is something that
isn't, again, you know, I'm
looking at the ideal
representation of it to make an
argument. But you know, these
woman, while the idea is set up,
that they can look, they can
move, they have to fall really
quickly. Right, but they do
ultimately have access to all
this stuff. Right. And there is,
sadly, it's actually not one of
the ones I pulled up here and
didn't use. But there's a great
ad that I found from the mid
1930s, from one company where
it's like, she controls your
history. Right. You know, and
so, you know, so you know,
there's like in that kind of
playful way, there's, like a
little bit of an acknowledgment
of it. But now, I'm rambling on,
because like, I think it's a
great question. But yeah, I
can't I can't give you something
about how to recognize the
question and say.
Andrew Whitacre: Yes, did you
see anything with filing
abinets use being unofficial o
subversive or illicit purposes
ithin corporations? I'm curiou
about how they might have bee
repurposed by employees. Yeah.
nd she says this question migh
be redundant, consideri
Craig Robertson: Yeah. You know,
it is kind of right. Yeah. But
again, I didn't, you know, that
part of it is the limitations of
the archive. Right. So the
archive skews to the official
literature, you know, in the
sense, right. And so, you know,
I, and it's, it's hard, you
know, like, I really didn't find
like diaries, or, or journals,
or something where that might be
recorded, or I was also looking
at the, you know, I was looking
at the archives of such as they
were of the companies, the
filing equipment, companies,
like the book would never have
been written, if I was going to
choose, you know, to really take
a deep dive into various
companies and how file cabinets
were used. So that's, you know,
that that's where I may have
found that right. But what I
didn't find in the how-to
literature, or the, or the
literature in a magazine like
Filing or any for its successor,
The File, which was more of a
pamphlet, was that I didn't find
people addressing that as a
problem. Which doesn't mean as
when we were talking about, you
know, the harassment of men,
sexual harassment, it doesn't
mean that it wasn't a problem.
But it definitely wasn't a
problem that was that was talked
about. But yeah, so what all
that comes in is misfiling,
which is understood to be a
distraction. Right, like from
distraction, not not
intentional. There's not an
intentional thing, you know,
it's a distraction, or it's
there, or it's stupid, right,
like, like a lack of, you know,
sort of, yeah, because these are
the daughters of immigrants,
right. So it's a lot of race. I
mean, I focused on gender today,
but obviously, it goes, you
know, that goes hand in hand
with race ethnicity, and as I
did sort of briefly nod to
sexuality.
Heather Hendershot: Well, I
think that we are pushing up at
630. So I just want to thank
Craig Robertson again for
joining us and I'll see you all
next, well, see you all in
class. You and our distance
folks at our Colloquium week
after next. Thank you so much.